not bad
I've got it I've got it all yeah
excellent hello good evening good
morning good afternoon wherever the hell
you are around the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel gentlemen we are live
so
today we're going to do the video we
were supposed to do last week or the
week before
something like that
um we're going to be talking about our
top five sci-fi shows of all time and I
mean shows and not franchises so if
you're going to say Star Trek you've got
to put the Next Generation or the
original series or whatever and you've
got to rank them first to fifth now I
did this because oh before we get we'll
get into that in a minute Matt
Harris how the hell are you says doing
well a lot better than being uh stuffy
and sickly so life is good
yeah I'm good as well it's been a long
time since you've been here missed it I
know I know it's been like like what two
weeks it's been since Wednesday for me
because I did a live Wednesday but you
know I'm doing a live again this
Wednesday with um with a chap from Gray
17 podcast we're going to be talking
everything from Babylon five so um I've
already set it up set a reminder now
guys if you want to come and join us for
that chat the reimagining of Babylon
five
um so yeah I saw a thing on Twitter
um somebody put out what is your top 10
favorite sci-fi shows and I'm like
that's too easy that's too easy oh five
pick it up five that's quite hard and I
even said at the time I've put five up
there now but if I do this again they'll
be different
and they are so I've got a different
five
um but I think I've just re-jigged it
all just slightly possibly but um but
we'll find out anyway if anybody
actually saw my tweet two weeks ago
they're probably gonna get in the
comments go that's not what you said
before I'm like no shut up leave me
alone
that is what we are doing today
gentlemen are we ready to do it
I believe so
Matthew are you ready to do it I am have
you just written them down in the last
30 seconds yes but they were already up
here because they're always there in my
head always
and in your heart
I'm gonna run the credits
[Music]
excellent right so
uh do you mind if I throw this I would
say what we're going to do today we'll
throw ours out there we'll make our
arguments for why we think these the
best and then at the end with you guys
helps in the comments I very much hope
we are going to
pick our top five our side Trek official
top five sci-fi shows of all time
um and we will argue Matthew will be
wrong
Harris will be American about it and
probably throw in some bloody nonsense
but of course
let's let's see what we come up with so
if I throw mine out there first you mine
guys or should we do each other's top
first actually let's start number five
and work our way up do backwards
yeah five
I have got the Orville
so and I'm gonna tell you my explanation
for this Star Trek the Next Generation
as a kid was always my favorite TV show
and it was obviously Seth MacFarlane's
as well because he obviously just went I
like that I would like actually
apparently probably went to he
apparently went to Paramount and said
I'd love to make a Star Trek show and
they went no so he went to Hulu went
kind of like Star Trek show and they're
like yeah as long as he's not called
Star Trek so we just didn't
um but it is basically the Next
Generation just with different engines
and a different Federation and
everything so
um
I like the show Mostly because of New
Horizons where it's been made slightly
more serious TV show now it's a proper
Sci-Fi show now whereas at first the
executives were sort of like can we
throw in some like humor in there you
know the Seth macfarl in this and he
didn't really want to do that apparently
he wanted to make a Sci-Fi show so he
threw in all the penis and fart jokes
um but as the show has got a bit more
popular or anything we're hopefully
going to be getting a fourth season
um as soon as Seth macfarland gets
around to writing it
um and yeah that's why I it's it makes
my top five my favorite TV shows in
history I love the Space Battles I do
love the occasional bit of humor I do
love the story lines he throws in and
they're very next Generation sort of
story lines but modernized in a lot of
ways it is woke at times but I don't
mind that I think the best sci-fi is
um very hard hitting very hard hitting
sometimes
just for context I've only just started
watching the Orville I'm on season three
I'm halfway through it
um and I've just gotten to an episode
um about the transgender storyline and
oh I almost cried it was it's such a
good story
yeah it's such a good storyline it's
obviously it's been going on since
season one but it's kind of all come to
a combination in season three
it's so good it's so good that's
beautiful that's not that is on my list
but it's not it's not number five for me
what is your number five number five for
me is red dwarf
yes
but
it's one that doesn't take itself
seriously it's a very slapstick very
like
it's just dry British humor and it was
when I grew when I grew up watching it I
didn't watch it because it was sci-fi I
watched it because it was comedy
but it had sci-fi elements to it and it
was just fun to watch and they were they
had all the the typical sci-fi tropes
there was time travel there was like
robots in it there were
sexy aliens you know the the kind of
things you'd expect from a normal
science fiction television show but it
was
funny and that was the main thing about
it it was just funny
and it's always it will always be one of
my favorites because I will always go
back to it and I'll always enjoy
watching it not the later Seasons mainly
like the original the original one when
they started making it for America when
it was popular and they started trying
to make it for America it went the
original run up until the point I think
when the crew of Red Dwarf all came back
before that it was it was great
yeah
so where I work
um I work in a school and on a Friday we
always go for uh fish and chips from the
school canteen I was in there on Fridays
my my colleague obviously he said what
do you want the the lady said what do
you want and he said fish and the first
line that comes to my head was the Cat
when he's at the the vending machine
he's going fish
fish fish
he's got the little thing on a fish tank
okay and then eat a little fishy
so good the cat characters fantastic if
you've never watched this Harris no I
haven't no I've heard of it it's this
mining ship and it um it had been lost
for like a million years and one of the
characters was like frozen in the stasis
because he it was a it was in jail
basically wasn't it something but anyway
he wakes up a million years later and
humanity is dead but his cat his pet cat
had evolved into an entire humanoid
species and so it's cat so he's yeah
he's a cat but he's a humanoid and it's
um the one thing that was never clear
but I think it was implied when Lister
went into stasis because he bought the
cat on board that's why he was in stasis
the cat was pregnant
and then that those babies ended up
becoming the cat people did Dave have
sex with his cat
and possibly so that's what I inferred
but it was never like said they never
said that
my favorite cat my favorite red dwarf
episode was the xenomorph one and there
was a it was an emotional vampire so it
sucked
um emotional states out of you and it
sucked list as fear out of him
so he goes so what are we going to do
what are we going to do and the
wonderful thing I say we run and then
Lister sort of wakes up after things I
say we get out there and we [__] it and
they'd like something I put that on a
t-shirt for sidetrack and they wouldn't
let me have it
well that sounds like right now like
what we do in the shadows I don't know
if y'all watch that but that's that
vampire show on uh FX and there's an
energy vampire is one of their roommates
or one of their flatmates
one of the best characters on television
right now it's it's hilarious
oh it's a fantastic show but yeah mate a
good shot there oh my my camera's going
crazy these lights
um right so Harris what is your fifth
well uh
if if if this doesn't tell you I'm still
a young buck uh it's kind of it's It's
new but it's also old I I'm actually
putting at number five the the new
Netflix version of Lost in Space I
really really liked it you know it's
solid it's got good emotions it is
fairly slow at times but I think that
slow those slow moments are really great
for character development
and I enjoy it I I don't think they uh
it could be very expositioning and
instead they just kind of trudge forward
and keep moving and I I like that out of
that show it's good it's a lot of fun
okay
and it's got a damn good soundtrack and
not go
at least once
um yeah I liked Lost in Space I thought
it was a much better to show the thing I
like how they brought bits from the
original series through into the new
series so I thought they were very
clever they walked that line
um see if anybody brings up Battlestar
Galactica anywhere on our list
um but they walk that line between
respecting the original making a new
show that actually worked sort of thing
so yeah okay and then lost in space that
is on the list not often reboots do that
well but I'd say that is a good reboot
yeah uh yeah it worked really well it's
a shame they um
a bit more humor a bit more
light-hearted in there and I think it
would have been even better but
never mind right so number four on the
list I'm gonna go first on this one so
number four on my list is Babylon five
B5
um a show I know you guys I I know
Harris you haven't really watched but
hopefully we're gonna be getting a
reboot of this very shortly
um
the reason why I love Babylon 5 was it
was done in a shoestring it was done for
almost no money
um some of the storylines were very
spiritual JMS the writer was it wasn't
he liked to talk about religion and
things but he didn't he did it in a very
spiritual ways and he seemed to imagine
like what religion in the future would
be like and I liked all that sort of
thing in the war between Humanity the
Shadows the vol-ons and the mimbari and
they said all of these all of these
different war in factions um
particularly in series three was really
the Pinnacle of the series it was
absolutely fantastic when they and
there's new Earth lines and things if
you watch any Sci-Fi series Babylon 5
Series 3 is one of the best it's like
the guys from Deep Space Nine watched
Babylon 5 and went let's do that
they really copied it it's like not even
not even pretending it's quite blatant
um
but the Shadows are still one of the
best villains in sci-fi they're just
fantastic the the vessels from it they
look like spiders
I imagine quite on purpose so that
scared the crap out of me immediately I
don't like spiders spiders are stupid
there's no reason to have that many legs
and and they know something we don't
know they just go remix I'm coming at
you and it's like [__] sake
um but yeah they're just it's just
fantastic and then they had such
brilliant characters like jakar and the
Centauri and thing it's just just a
perfectly rounded show it could be bored
at times
um I preferred it in season two when
they brought in Bruce Brock's Lander I I
proved him as Sheridan
um
it was just it's just just a great show
and like I say all rounded Sci-Fi show I
had a little bit of everything
um around an angry Russian in Ivanova
um it had
um bester who was played by oh I'm gonna
forget his name there but he played the
Russian Film Star Trek the Original
Series
um
um it just had
um it had psych psychics and I just had
everything so now that it easily makes
number four on my list fantastic show
and I hope they reboot it
Matthew number four on your list sir
number four on my list is travel zoning
Walter Koenig thank you check eight
Walter Koenig play best
fantastic sorry
Travelers
Travelers Travelers is a proud
Travelers is amazing it was made by Brad
right
it was like I had no idea it was made by
Brad like when I first started watching
and then realized Brad Wright made it
and then loved it even more and then
realized they were like the entire cast
of Stargate are in it
like it's so good
people from the future coming back and
taking over people who are just about to
die and then trying to save the world
it's like time travel it's sci-fi it's
ah and then it got canceled
three seasons
[Music]
they left season three on a massive
Cliffhanger where essentially the travel
traveler program gets Rebooted
um and essentially it was iteration one
over rebooting to travel aversion 2.0
and that would have been season four uh
but it never came to be yeah but it was
really really good really good
yeah I didn't like it I got bored I
watched it for about four episodes and I
got bored that's why you didn't like it
you need to at least watch the first
season because it gets it's the same
thing with a lot of TV shows the the
first season or the first half of the
season is generally a little bit slow
because it's just character building
you're just getting to know who the
people you're watching and then the
action kicks in but I think that very
much was the case with Travelers
but it was really good after that second
season and the third season are amazing
yeah and then it cancels on a
cliffhanger
yeah it's it's like it's one of them
it's kind of a cliffhanger and it's kind
of not so it's a cliff Wrangler in a
sense that he could continue and you
want it to continue but they left it in
a way where it could just end and it
could never be made again
so it does wrap everything up quite
quite nicely but
oh I just want it back I just want it
back
right okay Travelers
I've got it on the list
all right will it make our top five
Paris yes it will
so this one is a little more uh it is a
new show but I think it's near and dear
to all of us I I probably could have it
higher but the last season and a half
two seasons just didn't do it for me
like those first four hit you'll
probably already know what I'm talking
about it's old Mark hospi Mark otspie
and hot Mark Ferguson and the hot
godspeed whatever their names are the
expanse there we go I already forgot the
names but no I did it's the expanse that
show's just excellent on every level it
is it's as bad as sci-fi as you can get
while still feeling modern to a degree
feels like we would naturally kind of
evolve that way as a species as as a
planet where we're where we're going
right now and where we'll end up I love
it it just feels natural while also
still feeling like conceptual and just a
lot of fun because all the
there's a lot more than I just just
there's a lot more than just Space
Battles all the Thomas Jane and stuff
with uh the Prometheus and all that I
was just
it's interesting
I agree yeah expanse is fantastic it's
kind of like I love it if you were to
look at next generation or even like the
Orville or something they are very much
this is how we exp how we would like to
be perceived in the future whereas the
expanses no this is how we actually
would be yeah it's like it's I I don't
think there's any argument is it that
there's it's the most realistic Sci-Fi
series
yeah in a very long time I mean we get
there for the Odd Movie here and there
that you think there's a realism you're
not in the Martian and things like that
you know they're almost not sci-fi
they're almost um just but but yeah it's
it's definitely the most realistic we've
seen in a very very long time it's great
it feels I've always compared it just
because the last season and a half
aren't as good as the first so I've
always tried to like kind of compare it
to Game of Thrones it feels like sci-fi
is Game of Thrones in a lot of ways
where it was gritty it was real it
didn't hold anything back and
people died you didn't expect to die and
people got put into situations you
didn't expect to be put in situations
and yeah of course last year and a half
are still decent but still better than
most other I guess General sci-fi shows
or general fantasy shows for Game of
Thrones but the same way I just kind of
it didn't nose dive off it just
it teetered
yeah yeah I know what you mean I know
you mean no it's a great great TV sir
right so that's it number four the
expanse in I will did you see stormy did
give us this Vibe if we want to go ahead
and do those uh we'll throw them in as a
plus the honestly okay now let's let's
throw in stormies then I'll just go on
to my Twitter okay so he put the
expansion at number five
he put Stargate oh he hasn't read the
rules
I'll pretend he meant Stargate sg1 and
I'm assuming
um in number four okay right so we will
keep installing these as well so stormy
is but unfortunately working very very
hard at the moment so he can't join us
but
here that's sentences five right so
number three for me is a TV show that
didn't last very long
um 16 episodes or 12 episodes
16 episodes I think um but anyway
um it was canceled before it's time I
still cry when I'm alone at night when I
think about how it's canceled but then
we did get TV shows like Castle which
was brilliant and now the rookie which
is also brilliant and which we might not
have got if it hadn't been canceled on
the same thing but it was advertised as
a space cowboy
um TV series and even I 14 episodes
thank you
um he's jumping ahead though he already
knows I'm talking about
um even I thought it looked stupid he
didn't watch it when it was new so even
I'm to blame for white then got canceled
but Firefly was
again we're talking about a realistic
um sci-fi it really did have a lot of
elements to it that were genuinely
genuinely realistic the politics of it I
love that like the outer planets were
treated like second-class citizens and
the inner planets and so Stephanie and
places like that were the higher up um
you know the more important people and
they were like the upper class and you
know like they all had like
sword fights and things which was fun
um
it's a show that I think they keep
trying to reboot but it never can be and
I sing get Nathan filling to come back
because it'll just be generally hated
and
it's just a brilliant TV show because it
was funny it was clever it had some
really really good storylines in it it
was so popular it spun into a movie that
was actually then genuinely really good
as well even though they killed wash
which was just stupid what were they
thinking how easy would it have been to
bring that back if they'd just not
killed wash
just wasn't such a more I generally just
idiot
um
but it's just a great show and if you've
never watched it you're not sci-fi fan
and look who's not watched it
[Laughter]
it's on Disney plus I've seen an episode
watching immediately this is another
show you have to get tuned past
that it's a space cowboy It's a space
Western because it is a bit silly and
all the weapons and things are a bit
silly um but I promise you by the time
you get to the train
um Heist episode you'll be in love
and it's a very very character-driven TV
show you're absolutely adore I promise
okay so that is number three on my list
Firefly
Matthew number three on your list sir
number three on my list is the Orville
okay I've only just recently started
watching it as I said earlier
but I absolutely love it it's gonna go
back into my rotation of things that I
watch
excellent and I'll just cut out then for
a second nope
we just didn't care what you were saying
no it it lagged on my screen so I didn't
know if it lagged on yours as well
yeah it's going to go back into my
rotation because it's honestly it's just
one of the
it's just so good it's it the first
couple of Seasons yeah it's a little bit
more
slapstick I guess and they add a little
bit more humor into it but I kind of
like that
um
season three so far I'm only halfway
into it it is a lot more serious but
they still have elements of humor in it
which is yeah
yeah
uh but yeah pretty good I'm really
enjoying the the villain I always
imagined I was when I first started
season one I just thought the Krill were
gonna be the villain right throughout
the entire thing
but no now we've got the kalons
a head full of gun why not
the canines are great well I didn't what
I didn't get about that though in season
two when the when the kalon threat
happened and the all the evil ones the
guns come out their head there was a
previous episode in I think it was
season one where
um the doctor and uh Isaac were on a
planet and Isaac's there shooting with a
gun
he's got guns in his head why is he not
using the guns in his head
why does Daffy Duck put a towel around
his waist and then not wear trousers
it kind of feels like they only decided
to get guns in the head for that stuff
for that part of the story
but I loved how they had the data
character you know we're talking about
the Orville being a Star Trek thing we
have a data character and that was
um oh God I forgot his name
Isaac Isaac thank you so that was Isaac
that's my grandson's name for God's sake
right so they had Isaac
um and then I just love how they just
completely flipped it
you know they just sort of like went
actually we're going to call them turn
them into the bad guys I just love that
I thought it was so clever
um you know a brilliant TV show and I
don't blame you it's a good third place
Harris third place sir
well shall I show my age real quick Star
Wars
the Clone Wars I think is the third best
sci-fi television series ever made it is
seven seasons of greatness it was
canceled by uh
Cartoon Network that's the one I'm
thinking of and then brought back by
Netflix and then canceled again once
Disney bought Star Wars and then brought
back by Disney to be one of the I think
largest things that they've ever done
season seven of Clone Wars was huge for
them it has some the best fights in all
of Star Wars they're they're two fights
with Maul in that season that are
absolutely best absolutely some of the
best fights in Star Wars in general him
and Ahsoka fighting is wonderful and
then him his whole hallway scene
Star Wars is known for hallway scenes at
the moment
but Darth Maul has the best hallway
scene and he doesn't even use a
lightsaber he just uses the force and
cuts people's heads off with parts of
ships it's it's great it's it's insane
it should not be in a children's show
but it is and it is great because of it
I can't believe that shows a children's
show but it's it's it's great it is
seven seasons of wonderfulness and it
starts off a little rocky starts off a
little uh extra child-like and and slow
but when you get into that actual like
Rhythm of the show
I've tried watching it um I think I
watched the first couple of episodes and
I couldn't really get into it but that
sounds amazing what you've just
described so much carry on watching it
it's a whole different animal it's great
yeah
it's another one of them isn't it it's
probably slow at the beginning and then
it gets really good just have to do the
time
you would love it you could love it and
I'll give it a go at some point but okay
Clone Wars number three uh number three
for stormy bear is the X-Files now
that's the first show I think we've had
on this list that you've got to almost
think of like iconic when the first
X-Files came out
it was and it was just everybody watched
it you know it was actually I mean and
generally the first series is still one
of the the greatest first seasons of
Television it's just phenomenal
um don't get me wrong by the 10th or
11th season it was sort of like running
off a cliff and I tried to watch the
movie they did or the little mini series
they did not long ago and I didn't care
and I'm watching I know there's some
sort of um okay
um I just stopped watching I don't think
I I watched it past that but the first
season
and it was iconic like I said everybody
watched Exiles everybody
um
even me
well there's a Sci-Fi show that you
actually watched I know
excuse me for a second while I adjust to
myself
um but yeah I mean it was you know it
was phenomenal right number two on my
list is a little bit of a curveball
because I've actually gone for a Star
Trek series and remembering that I
always call myself a Trekkie all right
so I was I was all my My First Love was
always Star Trek
um but Deep Space Nine is my favorite of
the Star Treks
um I loved the battle scenes I I'm I am
a [__] for a space battle oh you have a
space battle I am I am just like a kid
with chocolate I love it I just love it
um I I even don't hate Star Trek Nemesis
because there's actually quite a good
space battle in it and the static
Nemesis is generally considered to be
one of the worst Star Trek movies manga
but the space battle and you know and I
I just love it
um so for me D Space Nine I loved that
they made it almost like a political
thing don't get me wrong the first two
seasons were born as Sin
um
but then they brought in the defiant and
the so just got way way better and they
started they've become a much bigger
show
um and as I say some of the battle
scenes are still stand up today and as
well the opening two episodes of Deep
Space Nine the first five minutes of the
first episode was incredible so in the
Next Generation Harris I'll have to
explain this to you because you don't
know what I'm talking about what a Star
Trek yeah exactly and Star Trek in the
Next Generation the first two episodes
of the Borg
um no sorry not the first two episodes
but when the Borg actually then attacked
the Federation it's called The Best of
Both Worlds and there's a battle at Wolf
359 what is that beeping noise is that
me or is that you guys
so that sounds like Discord but I don't
know it's not me not me uh well so
there's um so there's this battle at
wall 359. and the Federation get pasted
um but then Deep Space Nine the starting
sequence of Deep Space Nine is Cisco's
perspective of that battle and it was
genuinely brilliant and his wife dies
and I would go oh no I'm sad
um and you know then he gets transferred
to Deep Space Nine and then Picard
actually goes to Deep Space Nine and
Cisco's all like oh you
because then a long story anyway but
it's genuinely brilliant
um
and it had some of the best Star Trek
episodes but it was the first Star Trek
series to have like an overarching
storyline
um and there's been being copied ever
since but like I said it did copy
Babylon five a bit
so Deep Space Nine is number two on my
list I like how it copied it but you did
put it but uh higher up on the list
yeah
they did it better Alexa there's some of
the Space Battles I mean honestly it was
hundreds of ships against hundreds of
ships and then you see like the little
defiant going in and out of the big
Capital vessels in ours just great
um honestly good really good characters
again I loved Odo I loved I did like
Cisco in the end I had um a bit of a
Jones for Dax
both of them were gorgeous
um but anyway so number two on your list
um Matthew
this is not going to come as a surprise
to anyone but it's Doctor Who
and the Doctor Who is definitely
for the longest time it was my favorite
show
it's not my favorite show now
um
I think
largely because of the nature of this
channel I'm now going back and watching
more of a different show which is my
number one which we'll talk about in a
bit and
recently doctor who hasn't been great
but it's still up there it's still
one of my most favorites I mean I've got
a little davros here love Dad Frost it's
down for us I've got
my my cup of my desk is a TARDIS
I love doctor too oh and up here look
up here from the new from the latest
Doctor Who magazine
David Tennant
he's coming back oh
yes
his teeth he's already back kind of
we're not going to see him until
November which I'm I'm so annoyed about
they could have they could have done a
Christmas special they could have spread
it out throughout the entire year but
they didn't
until this November
power of the doctor on
like October 23rd or something last year
so I can't remember what day it was it
was a Sunday
um and then obviously we got the reveal
that David Tennant was coming back
and they said Doctor Who will return in
2023 and then there was loads of
speculation or maybe we'll get a
Christmas special finally because
Russell T Davis is back and he loves the
Christmas special
but no it's all going to be in November
so three episodes in November which is
better than what we've had
before in terms of anniversary specials
we only got one ten years ago and 10
beers before that we didn't even get one
but they could have spread it out and it
could have been amazing I I kind of feel
like they've announced a lot of stuff
too early because November is a really
long time away but whatever it's up
there it's still one of my favorite TV
shows hands down absolutely love it
Doctor Who
if we'd have done this list seven or
eight years ago Doctor Who probably
would have made my top five
I don't think it'll make my top ten
though
it would have made it would have been
number one on my list seven or eight
years ago yeah when Matt Smith I watched
it religiously I I absolutely
um but it does suffer for low budget
some of the storylines are just stupid
oh there's plastic Santas when their
hands [__] open they've got guns in them
they're always meant to be a little bit
silly it was just oh it's Christmas time
let's have an episode and they're always
meant to be a little bit silly so I I
can kind of forgive that but you are
right some of the storylines
are
I would describe them with a really bad
word that I don't want to say on stream
because with w and ends in k
um
some of the storylines are
oh okay
dog
yes I mean that too yeah some of the
story lines are dog poo yeah
but when you've got that's the thing
though isn't it when you've got a show
that's got such brilliant characters
you you you you see pasta because it's a
character-driven show I'm not going to
argue that fireflies and all their
storylines weren't brilliant but I
didn't care because the story the
characters were so great with BBC
because it's still a network
television show they get commissioned
for x amount of episodes and the
storyline doesn't necessarily always fit
those entire the entirety of the season
so there's always Filler episodes and
those Filler episodes are generally some
I say generally some of them are pretty
good some of them are just
I'll skip them yeah I'll skip them no
one does Filler episodes like Stargate
but anyway yeah
Harris number two on your list sir what
were you just saying about Stargate sg1
because that very well may be number two
on my list uh and it is I I am still
late in the game and it is the only one
that I have actually technically it's
not true because number one is in limbo
to a degree but number two as in
Stargate SG-1 is the only one on this
list that I have not finished yet I
still have I've only watched one episode
of season 10 because they took it off of
Amazon and uh I I haven't delved back in
because I I need Atlantis alongside it
and Atlantis is probably the one thing
that could come into the top five that's
not there yet so sorry lost in space but
it might be knocked out one day but I I
Adore Stargate sg1 there are some Filler
episodes but what I like about those
Filler episodes is they tend to be
instead of just like there are your
occasional okay let's re rerun
everything that we've done the past
season or rerun everything we've done
the past two or three seasons but those
aren't
typically at the Forefront of even the
Filler episodes the the filler tends to
be highly conceptual you get to like
actually engage your brain in like some
scientific kind of anomaly in some way
while still just being fun it was just a
fun show and it doesn't take itself too
seriously while taking itself very
seriously at the same time and it just
it just opens itself up for greatness at
every single angle and I think
accomplishes it most of the time
yeah I think so
um
it's very good at taking the science and
making it
obviously the science doesn't exist for
a lot of the stuff but it makes it
believable and this could happen this
could happen theoretically that's what I
like about it
yeah they'll take nuggets small nuggets
of things like like the black hole
episodes
such a clever way of taking
you know the gravitational force of a
black hole and turn it into a storyline
and it was just you know and then the
time Distortion and everything they
really got the details right even if
they didn't maybe get as accurate they
could you know they got as near as damn
it for somebody that's not a PhD in
astrophysics sort of thing to can bang
on really
um yeah I think Stargate won't be on
everyone else's list in a second so
we'll talk about SG on a little bit more
but number two on stormy's list um was
one we have to wear Mandalorian
um I've said before I'm not a Star Wars
fan I never have I don't I don't like
the Star Wars movies particularly I'll
I'll watch them don't get me wrong and
but I find him a little slow I'm not I'm
not fine I always prefer Star Trek when
I was a kid
um but the new Star Wars TV series are
just brilliant Mandalorian is brilliant
I like the book of Boba Fett one book
about when Boba Fett wasn't in them um I
like those two episodes he wasn't in
they were gray
um Mandalorian DeLorean season 2.5
yeah
um Mandalorian I found I nearly stopped
watching I stopped you know the first
couple of episodes I was like oh God
this is slow very good
um but then once I got it I was like and
or recently was genuinely probably one
of my favorite things this season this
year I thought it was fantastic if
season 2 was out it'd be in my top five
Yeah well yeah I mean yeah it's too
early to put it in a list like this but
um
if I was thinking top 10 I'm thinking
Mandalorian would be in the top 10 of my
list it's it's difficult for a series
when you're doing top five because
you've got to do really the shows you
absolutely love you know they've got a
place in your heart sort of thing but um
here it would be top top 10 I think it's
it's a fantastic show and again if we
come back in 10 years time and do this
list again
and we've had five six seven seasons of
Mandalorian and it keeps going at this
strength yeah it would make oh yeah I'm
absolutely adore it
um so number one on my list oh we're in
the big boys no I tell you yeah
before we do the top one like we'll just
quickly run our and we'll we'll we'll
stop for a break because here's the
adverts honorable mentions you're in
there we'll do honorable mentions
actually go go come back and do
honorable mentions one sec nine
chevrons.com
nine sharefronts.com is your dedicated
source for Stargate news which will aim
to complement this YouTube channel with
news that we have from our contacts at
MGM and Amazon breaking news about a new
potential Stargate series as well as
providing reviews and any potential
updates to new stories that we break
check out some of the news articles that
we have already at nineshavrons.com
also has some amazing merch get yours
today and show your support at
side-track.com
we're so professional
amazing
voice sultry sexy voice
um just perfect level just an alarm oh
yeah I mean and and the effects CGI
right
um honorable mentions those effects are
not good line
we do our best
um we'll do honorable mentions what I'm
doing is going to throw out a few of
what we've been going in the comments
so
um
I'll throw a couple named Harris Matt if
you want to throw a couple that you know
didn't make your top five but you know I
think so Fringe Andromeda Project Blue
Book a couple of the
um for me out of that Fringe
was a great chef particularly that if
you ever watch just watch the first
episode of the you know like the pilot
episode it's brilliant
um it's properly like the only other
series I can remember thinking the first
episode was that good was the strain
um which is like a vampire series that
had a similar sort of first episode
where there was this plane landed in
this the weird thing
um but the first episode of IT Fringe
towards the end I have to admit you're
watching it going what the [__] what
what nothing well they completely went
for a completely different storyline in
the fifth season it was it was print
like it was Fringe as we knew and loved
it season one to four and then all of a
sudden
oh we're in an alternate timeline now
yeah and it was weird it was good but it
wasn't like it wasn't it wasn't as good
as the last four seasons that was
actually that was originally my fifth
pick Fringe and then I remembered
actually no red dwarf because it's
it's one that I've gone back to watch
over and over again I've gone back to
watch French yeah no neither have I but
no it's a fantastic season I say
everyone must watch the first episode at
least have a house you got any other
honorable mentions you want to throw in
I've got a couple more here on the list
as well yeah I got I got four or five
for you real quick Mandalorian would be
a nine of course but stranger things
Rick and Morty and solar opposites even
though they're in a little hot water
right now but I don't think why did I
not think of stranger things stranger
things is awesome to say fine and I
never thought I'd be someone to say this
because I am I've said it on my Channel
streaming a couple times and I haven't
pissed anybody off yet too much
thankfully but I am not an anime person
long format anime I think is antithesis
to Art sometimes I I do not like it and
I will have that conversation one day at
some point somewhere but
short format anime as in the films and
then like the TV series that are like
three or four seasons long that
everything means something instead of
just a thousand episodes of BS
that is good and I have actually been
kind of forced to watch Attack on Titan
two weeks ago while I was a little
sickly this past week I'm on season
three now it's out of four it's great it
is great great
there's another show that I that I I
would put up there because it's one that
I go back to every every year when it
comes out but I don't know if you can
consider it sci-fi
it's the Umbrella Academy
it's kind of like superheroey it's it is
sci-fi
yeah well it's not it's got It's it's
like a comic book
show really
we use the word sci-fi Loosely there are
sciency fictiony stuff in there it says
portals and things yeah
it's one of them that I
I love it it's one of those different
Multiverse videos it's one of those TV
shows one comes along every now and then
that even my partner would like actually
like to watch it it's just good like
it's the science fiction of it doesn't
Define it
the characters are really good my
favorite character is Klaus who me and
my partner have always liked ever since
he was the the character Robert Sheehan
the actor sorry was in Misfits in the UK
we loved him in that and now
yeah that was I think that was probably
one of the main reasons my Miss wanted
to watch it because he was in it
um oh he's amazing I [__] love him if
I ever the best
classy number five yeah
very cool a couple of other shows that
have been mentioned in the comments
um Andromeda
with um Hercules in uh Kevin Sorbo
um don't follow him on Twitter
if you um unless you're an ultra
conservatist because some of the things
he says
are interested
um
Sarah Connor Chronicles which was
mentioned which we should have said that
was a great again canceled just as it
was getting good
um it's a great TV show but I wouldn't
pull it in my top ten I don't think it's
one of the all-time it is very good if
it had five or six seven seasons maybe
but not after one unfortunately unless
it's obviously Firefly in which case
no sorry
um logic there but
um somebody mentioned sliders
um which was a show again back in the
day very similar to Quantum Leap and a
lot of the way it was formatted
um a space above and beyond as well
which is again another season a series
that got canceled after the first season
and it shouldn't have done it should
have gone on to have at least five
seasons it was goddamn genius and that
is another show that hopefully is
supposed to be getting a reboot but it's
taking forever
um somebody mentioned Star Trek
Discovery if that's one of your five
favorite shows ever
I'm sorry you need to watch more sci-fi
stuff I'm sorry it's a good show and
it's beautiful oh well I've just been
for warehouse 13. that was a great show
I loved Warehouse 13. that was another
show that got canceled before it's time
um the guy that starred in it I don't
know his name but he was I loved him
um and the lady in It Happened very very
pretty
um but yeah
um now brilliant brilliant Warehouse 13.
I love how you used to do these big
shots of the warehouse and it was like
spotting all the weird crap in the
background there's a flying saucer in
one corner and this sort of things like
this
um a dragon skeleton and uh
um I liked how the warehouse had its own
personality and occasionally the
warehouse would turn on them like the
whole Warehouse itself isn't it anyway
brilliant so and did you have any more
honorable mentions before we tell us our
top
Top Choice
not necessarily off the top of my head I
think we we hit some good ones
okay yeah I can't think of any of my
head fantastic right so number one on my
list
um when Harris put this in as number two
I genuinely kicked him off the stream
um Stargate sg1 is not only my favorite
um of this of the franchise it's the
greatest Sci-Fi show ever made
um it it had the balance it had the
characters that we loved it had
storylines that were clever
it had humor it had drama there aren't
many TV shows that have brought me to
tears and Stargate sg1 is one of the
only ones that did
um I actually did my gold episode video
yesterday and put that up and I talked
about one of the depositing where he
dies and I'm genuinely like getting a
bit like
[Music]
um
it's made me laugh more there's been
very very few TV shows but that when it
was on
I it made my day remembering that it was
Thursday and the Stargate sg1 was on
tonight you know what I mean
um Atlantis and SGU were good what SG-1
was the daddy and it always will be it's
it's my favorite Sci-Fi show ever made
and I think it always will be
good for me it's number one on my list
as well it's
for every reason you've just said but
also
it was one it's one like a lot of TV
shows I think have they they suffer from
dragging things out
Stargate didn't really do that
it had it did it did drag out the guy
wall bit but it did it in a way that it
was fresh each time so we had a puffers
and then we had Soca and then we had
Anubis but it was different each time it
wasn't like oh it's just another Apophis
it's just another so-called just another
one it was different each time they
added things to it and it was fresh and
it was interesting and it was the stakes
just kept getting raised higher and
higher and higher
especially with Anubis being a half
ascended being it was yeah it was
interesting to watch very interesting
and I was looking forward to the next
episode every single time it came out
but um I said before I'm I'm someone who
can't wait to watch TV TV shows so I
will always get the the versions from
America before they come to the UK
because in the UK we get well not so
much nowadays but in the past we would
have to wait like 10 weeks or something
with syndication
and uh I'm like no no I'm not doing that
I'm just gonna watch it from America
yeah I did not want to Choice myself
the whole thing with Stargate though was
that yeah I just I loved sitting down
waiting for it to come on the
anticipation I didn't mind waiting and
how many series you've ever done you
know when it has the Cliffhanger which
they didn't always do with Stargate but
the one to two series they had the
Cliffhanger one I'm like
you can't do this to me please don't do
this to me and then you have to wait
like six months for it to come back
you're like no and and to have that
emotional response from a TV show for me
is
um is quite
it's quite right they had a couple of
big Cliffhangers that I was surprised
they had between like Seasons I just had
to kind of put myself in the in the spot
because you know I'm just binging it so
I'm like all right go to the next one
but
because they thought they were going to
get canceled so they ended it on a
massive Cliffhanger or something like
that the most epic thing you can think
of
and then they get renewed and like oh
crap we've got renewed let's just carry
on then
it worked out so well like y'all I'm
still talking about the gold I still
haven't finished I love Anubis Anubis is
going to be as crazy as I'll get out I
know it is
but I still want to see what happens to
ball I'm still having fun with ball you
know I'm still in that last season I I
don't know what exactly happens and I'm
just enjoying it I'm ready for it to be
back on Amazon
that's better but when they say when I
say they don't drag things out in a bad
way ball coming back
I'm not I don't want to say too much
because you haven't seen too much of it
but the way
he's my favorite it's so much fun I love
him I'm so glad I never know that's so
sad he's dead in real life because I
would love it
yeah
no way if Chris Simon died yeah he was
in a surfboarding accident I think damn
he looks like a surfer you know yeah I
said in my video yesterday that's such a
glint in his eye I said that he's a boy
that would get away with anything you
know when he was a little kid he just
got away with murder villain he's like
I'm just gonna flush your wallet down
the toilet dad
um but yeah okay now Harris what is your
number one because it's not Stargate so
all right
after wrench in there real quick and and
scold you all for not putting this
anywhere on the list how can you not do
a top five sci-fi list without Futurama
on there Futurama is the best future
it's Futurama do you know how many
people like sci-fi just for the fact
that Futurama exists it is so good I'm
talking about conceptualism talk about
no filler talk about just keep going and
keep going on with good ideas Futurama
is just it it gets better and better and
that's why I was also like well it is
renewed so I can't say we finished it
but we've all watched it through 17
times over I mean I I wouldn't no I have
watched I've watched pretty much every
future armor episodes I do like it but I
don't I don't I don't know if I consider
it like one of my top I just watch it
because it's funny it's I don't know but
then I watched the Orville because it's
funny
I'm ready
Futurama has the best depiction of the
concept of I'm not the most religious
person I have been in my life before but
Futurama has the best con concept of God
of any television show that's ever been
done just watch that episode and you'll
be like oh wait a second if you actually
go in and do future like Futurama is
just as conceptual and they are very
like
of course the science isn't perfect
because it's all it's conceptual science
but they make sure that it makes sense
to a degree everything in Futurama has
I'm not going to say it's like Big Bang
Theory like scrutiny but it's not far
off they actually make the the math all
makes sense I love it I love it it's
great I'm glad you didn't say Big Bang
Theory is your top top one to be honest
ah Rick and Morty and solar opposite
things like that wouldn't exist without
Futurama we wouldn't have modern sci-fi
Futurama Rick and Morty very completely
separate categories for me I love both
of them yeah I wouldn't consider them
like
they are sci-fi but they're cartoons so
they're in a completely different box
for me
completely different box I'll go back
and watch them because I enjoy that kind
of stuff but
um
I thought
if I comment we'll never see Harris
again so I'll make him cry I'm telling
unlike
um so we'll okay look you are entitled
to your opinion however wrong it is you
are entitled and nobody can take that
away from you give me a season and then
report back
I've watched I've watched Futurama I've
watched it
all time favorite sci-fi shows ever
it's so good it's so many seasons of
just greatness
oh yeah right now like it's on the list
it's written down all right I'm putting
I'll put a big question mark next to it
and I've written WTF
um which what
um
what the actual anyway
we're all entitled to our opinion Harris
I mean you don't let anybody else tell
you any different oh I will never
um stormy
um as actually thrown a thing anyways
and I think he's got a good argument
here but he's put Battlestar Galactica
and I'm going to assume he means the
um Ronald D Moore version
um
again I know Harris you haven't seen it
go and watch the mini series in
particular I I don't think this is the
greatest series ever made but the mini
series that they made
it's difficult not to say that that is a
truly truly brilliant piece of sci-fi
and got copied after it a lot and you
always know when something's really
groundbreaking and really brilliant
because everyone copies it look at the
Matrix movie and then every film for the
next bloody 10 years after it um
everybody's all of a sudden wearing long
leather coats and
um things so I I think Battlestar
Galactica and then number one is not a
bad shout at all to be honest but right
that is our top fives we now have to in
four minutes and 36 seconds and pick
the Sidetrack top five the official
top five of this Channel and I can tell
you now [__] Futurama is number three
number one anyway well I can argue for a
top five but it will not be in
um it will not get number one Iris you
always God love you
um but I gotta throw a wrench in there
somewhere yeah I love it I love it right
so
I I think we have to pick our number one
and work the other way don't we because
we have to because because this is going
to get confused enough yeah so we know
number one
number one are we can we agree as a
family as a side transfer family it is
yeah
okay I'm doing the official doing the
official list right so Stargate sg1 are
we happy with that
period Harris isn't Harris is thinking
but Futurama
yeah
number two on the list well I'm telling
you that the only other show that we
actually none of us
agreed on
that's an interesting thing about this
as well is that we've got very different
lists
you know I mean I got sg1 ds955 the
Orville harrisab future armor
Stargate Clone Wars the expanse Lost in
Space Matty had sg1 Doctor Who the
Orville Travelers Red Dwarf stormy
bastard galactor Mandalorian X-Files
Target sg1 and the expanse
there's another crossover though I think
that the second place would have to go
to who who had the most most votes so in
that instance it would be the experience
or the Orville because they both had two
votes but I would put the expanse above
the Orville
it didn't make my list but it would go
above the Orville
I think the expanse even though it's
maybe not my favorite I I do love it I
respect the crap out of it yes and I
think from a a respect point of view
that this is the most grown up of all of
the sci-fi shows and even though maybe
it's not the most entertaining at times
it can be you know it's it's it takes
itself quite seriously and it should
oh yeah um it's I respect the crap out
of it and I and it is one of the few
sci-fi shows I've watched again and
again
so yeah okay I'm happy with the
expansion at number two
um Harris you're out of this
conversation a little bit but do well
actually no actually Sarah she wants a
conversation do we need to put a Star
Wars or a Star Trek in number three
because it's the two of the biggest
franchises or Doctor Who I I don't think
we should be holding ourselves to that
it's just what we uh like a true opinion
I don't you know
but I would put Doctor Who in a third
personally because it may not be to
everyone's taste right now but
it has always been one of the greatest
TV shows
historically it was one of one of the
biggest shows on the planet like 10
years ago for that four or five season
run it had what are we doing generally
or are we doing us
well we're doing this but this has got
to be the channels
official top five okay so
um
I think there's an argument for
Battlestar Galactica
as well
it was genuinely groundbreaking
they say I've never seen it but if the
what people difficult universe is true
well what people say about universe is
true where it was pretty much a a Battle
Star Galactica like clothing then
stylist yeah I would
Jay you installed
right yeah yeah so technically vote wise
it would be third right okay
all right let's put Battlestar and then
it
isn't it yeah
if not Battlestar okay
uh who else did we have Futurama Battle
Star battlestar's only got one vote the
expansion to the Orville
got to
so hard for me to put the olive oil in a
top five for all time though
has it earned it
Battlestar out of this right the mini
series was amazing
the series actually
got a bit I'm not even sure I ever watch
it to the end I think I got bored
but the mini series was amazing and it
was ground broken
I would rather put Babylon five
in the top five than Battlestar
but that's why I did put Babylon five in
my top five minutes
um
oh guys help us out in the comments here
guys what you thinking I I'm thinking of
Star Trek or Star Wars series I've got
to go in here
well
I of course I would say the Clone Wars
just because man Mando isn't finished
yet but I feel like Mando may be in one
of those top five just because that's
something that we can all agree and like
not just agree with yeah that's right
but agree with yeah that's that's fun
you know it's more uh brings a little
more life to the conversation
um but I don't know if it deserves
number three it might be a number four
or five because once again it's not
finished yet you know and I'll say a
series that we've actually none of us
have mentioned with Star Trek the Next
Generation
which again from
You could argue that there wasn't a lot
of sci-fi in the TV when Star Trek the
Next Generation came on
um sci-fi had become
um you know second-class citizen sort of
thing it kicked off what I would think
is the Golden Age of sci-fi and TV you
know it would Babylon 5 got made because
of this and and the Sci-Fi Network
itself you know you could argue
popularity we wouldn't have got Stargate
and all these things so is there an
argument just to say for the importance
of the show
and the characters to Stargate the Next
Generation Star Trek the Next Generation
deserve to be on our list even though
none of us have said it's our favorite
it's only not on my list
yes
because I've not I've not seen it all
and
I do really enjoy it I think it's a
really good show
and I think you're right there is an
argument to be made
but it
kind of kicked off the Sci-Fi thing was
stuck like that in that era it gave
Credence to Stargate being born and
everything else so
I mean I'm happy to pull it in there
right although I don't know I haven't
seen it at all and put the Star Trek the
Next Generation is officially
because of its importance was that third
or fourth third
so fourth and fifth we've got two spaces
Left Right
Doctor Who has to be in there somewhere
four does it okay
yes it does it does I I would fight for
Futurama over that one sorry
out of my list I I would if I was going
to pick one more I would I would fight
for Babylon five if you guys had to pick
one out of your list that you had to
really like oh no they really deserve a
space here what would you go for Doctor
Who yeah okay
Harris do you say Futurama seriously I
will come and find you how dude how
pissed off do you want me to make it
real quick
just right prior to Stargate right prior
and I would are I I don't know for sure
but I bet you if you asked Brad Wright
he would have gotten a good chunk of
Concepts from Futurama he probably is
he's got his pulse on on he's got his
hand on the pulse of a lot of sci-fi I
would assume but I think a lot of this
Concepts from Stargate may not have been
there if not for Futurama and every
Sci-Fi show after Futurama aired
has something to do with it it inspired
it in some sort of way
it's just it's too pivotal I just find
it hard to believe that Brad Wright
would be sat there watching the future
armor and going that would be a great
storyline for Stargate
we can ask him one day let's let's do it
I would put money on that conversation
he follows me on Twitter I will uh that
was they're so good on my birthday I
gotta I woke up in those names he only
he only um follows a couple hundred
people
this idiot's one of them I think he's
just following me to watch what I'm
doing really just to make sure I don't
do anything else he annoys him which
also means subscribe because we're we're
officially verified in the Stargate
world and somehow that way right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're Legends
now we are the start as far as I'm
concerned with the Stargate Channel damn
right
we're the ones that are actually balls
out actually given information that is
actually like relevant and up-to-date
and you know okay a few rumors and
things with with the channel that's
talking about you know I mean video
Stargate um sorry the
um
was it gate world to actually do I do
more videos in them a week and they do
on a bloody year so they're doing it so
I think you should legally change your
last name of the star game so you can
just go around it
kind of the real gate world
anyway
um wow
um
uh yeah right so I am going to say that
as an executive decision and the founder
of Sidetrack I'm making an executive
decision
I'm going to put Doctor Who in at number
four
even though I don't
um particularly like it at the moment
and I don't think it's great I you have
to respect the history and I think we've
seen it
um this see this list is based on the
importance of the show as well and
Doctor Who from sci-fi is one of the
most important franchises it's the
longest running franchise in history
it's it's influenced so much other other
sci-fi you can't leave it off the list
and at number five iconic TV shows of
all time really
people who even people who don't like uh
sci-fi I think there's
possibly like three television shows
even people who don't like sci-fi will
have heard for heard of Star Wars Star
Trek Doctor Who yeah
because there are people who have no who
who like those kind of things but I've
never heard of Stargate like anyone I
ever work with the first thing I've ever
asked them is do you like Starkey and
they're like they're always like what's
that
we think it's the greatest television
show of all time but it's not the most
iconic Star Wars Star Trek and Doctor
Who people the three main pillars I
think you know it yeah but how often
just coming from I guess the American
point of view here is I don't know if I
could walk the street and get a single
people would know what Doctor Who was
but I don't think a single person I
tapped on the shoulder would have seen
it and you know I I I think 10 10 years
ago didn't maybe when but then again on
the Matt Smith area it was it was really
big in America it was huge in the UK but
it was really it was quite big in
America if if we're talking like
importance of sci-fi though even though
it was only one season wouldn't Firefly
just because it's that beloved of sci-fi
in general almost have that's that same
argument I guess in a way
I think Firefly is more like a cult
following the people who liked it really
like the people who watched it really
liked it the people who haven't watched
it don't know about it and they're not
going to talk about it it's not
something that's talked about
in other uh in other forms of media
whereas things like Star Wars Star Trek
doctor who they they crop up in
um in TV shows all the time I mean
there's uh what there's a TV show I
think I think it's like is it Community
something like that some some American
TV show and they've got an in-universe
TV show called
like phone box man or something and it's
essentially Doctor Who I can't remember
what TV show it is but they've
essentially just found the community
that kind of stuff they've just
paralyzed Doctor Who he's got he's got a
telephone box and everything and he
travels in time and he's got a companion
it's Doctor Who but they just can't call
it Doctor Who and that's what I mean it
crops up everywhere it's like so many it
just entrenches itself into society
to the point where people just reference
it and everyone knows what it means yeah
and then number five is Firefly I've
done it
oh it may be in a couple of Seasons what
about Futurama
oh I forgot my Futurama sorry we'll do
top six
um so our official top five sci-fi shows
of all time sg1 because it's just the
best the expanse because it's the most
grown up the most sensible the the most
Auto the Next Generation because it's
kind of the daddy of sci-fi and without
it it it relaunched Star Trek it
actually gave birth to the Golden Age of
sci-fi for me which was the late 90s
early you know the late 80s early 90s
you know through
um Doctor Who in at number four because
it's iconic and at number five Firefly
because
that's the show for me that was it's
it's the show that got canceled early
and it is the biggest travesty
it's so we've got a reason for each show
being on the on the list is what I'm
trying to say it didn't deserve to get
canceled and it's a crime
um and
you can also bite my shiny ass
and there
it's the greatest it's just the greatest
show so I I've made a decision we're
doing
next week gentlemen
how do you fancy trying to pick the five
greatest Sci-Fi movies of all time
you're trying to make it I'm not like
each other anymore we're just gonna this
is gonna be
um
Futurama movie before we [__]
there
aren't any other not that I know of
so before we get into that though so we
we might have some rules for one will we
allow sequels
yeah you have to Empire Strikes Back I
mean that's just the first thing that
comes to mind
excellent okay then um no franchises so
it's individual movies and you've got to
pick your top five
um again you can have your favorite so
you can throw some in there just because
they're important or ever and then we
will pick our great our top five Sci-Fi
movies of all time now remembering
Harris that the world didn't start in
1995. so you're gonna think about
actually 1995 you were three
um no I was I was two years from being
known now I was four I can't even the
math and I'm 99 I was four years from
being born there right okay the year
didn't start in 2010 then you've got to
actually go back so one of mine's
already a 60s movie and I got three over
the 90s at all you're saying
so you don't remember the 90s you
weren't conscious enough to remember the
night oh no I'm a 90s Baby by
technicality and I'll take it
so now I will say it has to be
full-blown sci-fi
sci-fi-ish horror movie we'll discount
it and we'll do a different video flat
of some other point all right okay so I
want pure sci-fi
okay
um science fiction
um okay so so Empire Strikes Back would
not count because Star Wars it's a
little harder and disqualify the big
franchises
so we will disqualify Star Wars
we'll just say look they're brilliant
we'll give honorable mentions we'll have
a little bit of Star Wars bit in the
chat all right yeah but it's a space
fantasy and it's not necessarily it's
not sci-fi like what we're talking about
it's space fantasy completely yeah
we'll disqualify Star Trek
you've probably never seen the films
anyway
um is there any other big ones
I tell you what we'll disqualify the
Marvel movies and things like that as
well not that they would make a hive
anyway but they're not really sci-fi so
superhero movies will disqualify okay
so that is it those are the rules
no Star Wars no Star Trek and we'll
disqualify
um the thing and we'll have a little bit
of a chat on the end about which is the
best let's disqualify Stargate as well
then
uh TV movies should we disqualify TV
movies well yeah there's the original
Stargate movie which was
if we're disqualifying Star Wars and
Star Trek it's fair to disqualify star
game they only did one film though yeah
I don't even think about that for a
second but if we're being fair
it's that's not fair though is it
because Star Wars is a franchise of
movies they made nine
Stargate the Star Trek they made nine
but honestly we might not even want to
count out Star Trek because it is true
sci-fi Star Wars even though I love it
it's it's my bread and butter in a lot
of ways it's space fantasy but Stargate
and Star Trek are both
true sci-fi okay right that's a good
argument actually so um things like as
well like Willow and things like that
it's fantasy it's not sci-fi so yeah so
so
style get the Star Trek we're not doing
Star Wars
you can have started mate if you're
picking a Star Trek movies your top five
stars
but you might I don't know I'm not
I very much doubt it anyway
um no superheroes
see how we get on all right okay then
and no horror right no no like sub-genre
no no sci-fi horror
anything that is It's gotta be pure
sci-fi so yeah if it's if if we have a
go is that really sci-fi and you have to
explain it it's not okay okay so like
the Fang or alien or aliens would count
yes okay all right okay I'm with you
what maybe like that new doll movie
maybe Megan yeah
so because that is that is more horror
than sci-fi
ish I would argue
well it's basically if you're not sure
get rid of it
okay that's a general rule so no no
Horrors nothing because then it's like
Event Horizon where would you put that
is it a horror movie or is it a sci-fi
movie
yes yeah I would argue Event Horizon is
a horror movie
okay
the sphere
I would argue is a sci-fi movie with a
bit of horror
um
so would alien be a horror movie set in
space but aliens be a sci-fi movie
we could make an entire livestream just
debating what's arguments
do y'all want us to do a live stream
about just coming up with some rules
because we could come up with yeah let's
just go with that and okay as a general
rule so if you're not sure don't throw
it in but then throw it into your
honorable mentions all right okay good
idea can you think of like that I'm not
sure this is a Sci-Fi me but I love this
film for me like Event Horizon would be
up there for that that's a perfect
example of a film that I don't really
think is a is a balls out sci-fi movie
it's more of a horror film but it is
[__] brilliant and they're still
looking at potentially the Remake is
maybe still on the card so things
crossed me I think that'd be great it's
actually might be streaming it might be
actually be a series a streaming series
which I think could be great
um so yeah
that is our list and gentlemen we have
done it we set out to do something and
we freaking did it what I know it's in
today's time I know and yes well stormy
wasn't here so we've finished we're
feeling a bit late but not massively
right we still include I'm just within
in heart and soul of course and lifts
and I'm really proud of that well done
I'll tell you what if we we do this same
conversation next year it'll be
completely different except star games
do you want to still be top but then
yeah
our completely new arguments
no it won't Paris Futurama will not be
in my channel
I've got faith it would be my top five
sci-fi cartoon shows actually no I
probably wouldn't because at some point
where would that be walking down the
road you're gonna be walking down the
road a van is going to pull up Harris is
going to kidnap you put you in a room
hold your eyes open everything
I love the show it's just not going in
uh top five if he's gonna beat you he's
gonna beat you every time yeah what's
the greatest show what's the greatest
showman you're not going to go home okay
um
so yeah that is it guys so thank you so
much for coming everybody in the things
look
we'll do more videos like this because
it's just you know the everybody you can
see that it's been fun and we've had
really good numbers and everybody's been
in the comments and everyone's been
absolutely crazy in the comments like
you know
um hope we miss out Farscape I love
Farscape it was a great show and if I
was doing top 10 it would make a top ten
it just didn't make much up five but it
would this is why top five is hard you
know yeah
um
that's why it makes it harder than the
top ten but yeah it's been absolutely
fantastic yeah Claudia Black was in it
Woody block went into Stargate sg1
they're just like do you mind if we just
put you in leather all the time and
she's like yeah whatever and we were
almost like yeah her character's great
her and ball are like
giving me life for season 10. I I need
to finish it and I need to finish on
with a season three of Atlantis
uh
correct come on Amazon
come on
anyway thank you so much everybody again
we will see you next week for our top
five Sci-Fi movies of all time
spec'd debate I'm just waiting for
Harris to just say something really
stupid oh I'm ready to piss everybody
off I'm excited
Futurama the movie [__] you Harris
guys so bye-bye
see ya
bye bye everybody
foreign
[Music]